this
particular talk is about our love for
interfaces
and uh we're going to use one of the
first big projects
in code that we did at club which was a
later called spanx
so before we go into wiring our places
and how we make everything better
uh i want to give some sense of what
space is
swings like i said this is an http rate
limiter
it exists completely outside of our
applications that sits on top of
every api request that comes into play
it's really configurable in terms of
you can create a lot of different limits
and you can select
what requests apply to which limits
and how you construct keys
uh so that you can use multiple axes or
compound axis to
limit users or ip addresses on
one of the things that we had to do was
to also build the leaky bucket
library which the space regulator is
built on top of and it's also simple
we found that benchmarks were really
awesome because from the very beginning
we knew
how each component how much time each
component took
and uh we were able to get for even
complex requests
some uh 15 millisecond latencies
on top of our existing infrastructure
which is important since every request
for statistics
uh sometimes with lots of uh large
payloads that we have deposited
so um i want to do one more thing before
we dive
into uh the actual construction of build
off space from the bottom up and that is
what is unlimited um i'm not sure if
everybody's
has used it before but general you
define
the maximum number of requests that you
can make for
interval we don't do any
traffic shifting we can have no question
about this
and then you also then describe a
matchup based on request
properties of which particular events a
request should be
tested against and like i said before
you could decide that
you know i want to create a limit that
is
unique to every id that i get request
from or
i want to create a compound key where
every ip for every user has a given
limit
so any questions before we dive into
interfaces
yeah you might get to this later um i'm
curious what procedure you use to do
as much as it
so there's two major ways of doing
weight limiting one
is that let's say let me take an example
i set an interval of 10 seconds
and i want to set 200 requests as the
level we do not do traffic shipping
which means that the request will always
be equally
spaced between the 10 seconds that
makes it very hard for
developers using your api and you know
what is going on
because a request might fail and the
other one might go through
or you have to cue every request
and hold on all the connections before
you learn through so for
the
implementations out in the wild never do
traffic shipping because of those
reasons
uh traffic checking does become
important at much more lower levels than
maybe dealing with packets
but http requests it seems like
how we use interfaces to make building
stinks uh really easy
um sort of what benefits you have from a
software engineering perspective
um so first for those of you who aren't
familiar with interfaces and go
basically the interface defines
a list of methods and then any struct
that has those methods influence that
interface
so like as an example you might have a
structure called iq limit key
which implements our limit key interface
because it has
a key function so this is like how we
implement
different um ways and regulatory rules
you write when people buy ip
or header or path or any sort of thing
like that there's just different
implementations of the same interface
so how did interfaces help us and go
very bumps
so they came with benefits for
collaboration and
testing as well as applying software
behavior
so let's jump into like collaboration so
when you're starting on a project
the common questions you ask are like
who works on what and where about starts
uh and that can often be a hard problem
with a very large project um
all these different components have
different dependencies on each other so
if you have to have some sort of like
hierarchy whatever you work on them in
unless you use interfaces and then you
can define your interfaces for your
components ahead of time uh and
then you're not dependent on other
components in terms of like what order
you build your faces
in um so that allows flexibility
it allows you to not be blocked by your
teammates um
just like across the board better with a
better way to do
live projects um so that's an example
here
for spanx we made this like great lender
interface was like the first thing that
they made which is like
the course things like big space is a
rate limiter and it has interface
that takes in a request and returns
information about
whether or not that request is limited
if so why it was limited and how it was
limited
then anything that um on this interface
can
provide the implementations of the
interface or like
use their own mac implementations
whatever they want to specify
arbitrary behavior um as well as
doing like assertions on results of uh
expected yes setting up arbitrary
behavior for what the limit does as well
as setting expectations what women is
going to receive
um that makes sense we're not going to
go too much now this code most people
want to
use like lots of third-party libraries
so like um
yeah um yeah
so um before before i move on so anyway
so i know
one of the things is like one of the
things that we were very excited about
using interfaces
like we all learn about like using
interfaces
in like context of school but um you
never
it's always too much overhead to
actually use it in real projects
but in our first project circle we found
that since interfaces
were so lightweight and we could easily
change them and it would
the compiler would tell you what other
things you need to change
uh it was it was very low cost to add
these interfaces and iterate
so i guess uh to give you some context
over the first week we changed the
interfaces and stepped from each other's
toes all the time
but after that we were able to build
different parts of sphinx
and you know even build the top layer
before we had any other parts running
which was the http part which we were
very excited about perfectly
and so we talked about the mark based
interfaces but
there are other ways that we found
testing was great with
well specifically focusing on interfaces
for our nikki bucket library
in general what we really wanted to do
was to have at least two implementations
which was an in-memory implementation
and our latest implementation
so what that means is that if we had
multiple circles running we wanted
to compute in one place what limits
would be uh and
but we as we continue to development we
wanted those implementations to stay in
not just in terms of their interface but
also their behavior
so what we and that usually becomes hard
and also we were finding different bugs
in the implementation
because uh they were being used in some
companies
being used in changing other words being
used for tests
and so we wanted to work on it in a way
so that bugs found in one interface with
automatically always tested for all
implementations
so what we decided to do for that was
write the tests
on the interface as opposed to on the
implementation
and that meant that within that library
all implementations run the same tests
or they have to explicitly state that
they are skipping a test by
uh re-implementing a different uh an
empty version of it
um so so this is a basic
interface in leaky bucket it is a
storage
and you can create a name a name
expirable
key so you basically have a
total number which you over time you can
implement and it expires after a certain
time
uh so let's look at the tests that we
wrote for this interval
interface so we don't have any
implementations yet
and what this test does is so the code
in the middle what it does is it creates
a bucket
and then checks that the input
parameters that we
send which in this case is 100 times
minute
were actually the ones that were
returned as the properties of the bucket
we got back
so this is an example test and what
we're doing is that we're taking an
implementation
of storage as the input and returning a
function
to run the test on top on it and so
basically
there are there is a
main function that returns a lot of
these tests that are the base test that
every implementation
can run so for example
the two implementations that i talked
about in memory and redis
actually need to be instantiated in very
different ways so you can't really
just run the test on them but as you can
see the way
by returning a function that is test
given uh instantiation of
each of the implementations what we all
we have to do is so for example
on the top block the memory
implementation is instantiated just by
saying you
whereas the redness implementation means
uh that is
to create awareness and then they both
run the same tests so we know
that the variables are same we have
launched the tests in the library around
race conditions and uh kind of like edge
cases
uh on the median algorithm that are
understood at both instances and we know
that certain has
failed on particular instances
so other benefit we got from interfaces
so um basically
we talked about uh different
implementations of the same interface
with the same behavior but different
like backing structures
um you can also do things that implement
the same interface with different
behavior
we got a lot of benefit from that as
well so um
we wanted to be able to change behavior
or weight limiter just by changing our
like configuration
um so the way we did this is
uh anybody making sure the limits that
we'd set were reasonable like
we weren't having partners hitting our
limits all the time um
yeah um and that was a hand swappable
just like a single config line so that's
pretty easy
any questions on that i guess
yeah so um one of the other things that
happened
as we continued building the project is
that
new people getting onto the project uh
required a lot of context around
what were all the things that happened
that that were happening in the pipeline
and what
was going on but what we wanted was for
people to be able to contribute
new matches and keys uh two
so matches are basically what property
do i pass off the request to make
decisions based on
and then what what properties can i use
to create keys
and this could be like request paths
params ip address
headers and we wanted people to
contribute these over time
and what we struggled a lot with trying
to figure out what's the best way to do
plugins in
go and that's an active discussion topic
that
we keep part of in lots of things from
discussion spaces
but uh for for now the solution that we
came up
does require recompiles however we
use some of the information that we
already built
to provide uh easy ways to
add things test them know that the
entire system works and behaves in the
right way without
understanding all different part systems
and
so i want to give an example by using
the matches which basically decides
whether a particular limit will be
applied to an incoming request or not
and so it's pretty straightforward the
matching interface is just takes in a
request
and returns true or false and the only
thing that we
the thing that we required was to also
every matcher has to implement a matter
factory
which is a javascript but it helped us
to not predefine configuration for these
so each
each matcher can define what
configuration they expect
in our yaml based or dictionary
configuration file and it returns
so we have two functions there a type uh
which returns a string
which basically is the yammer field that
we pass and then
find using reflection which ones of
these matches
should be called and the create which
actually we just pass
in a block of unpassed yaml to them or
the dictionary object and they are
responsible for parsing
and so the bottom half is basically the
example of the path matcher which is
just
a simple like it takes in an array of
regular expressions and
sees if the path matches any of them uh
and you can see that it defines its own
structure
and so the create function actually
passes that into
the yama structure and we call the
create functions for every
matcher when sphinx first loads up
before starting to forward any requests
so that we know that all of the matches
will load up correctly
so this what does help us and this also
really helps in tests
so if you are adding new manager for new
features to sphinx
they are tested completely with requests
and just the loading part
and just whether they need to succeed or
fail without you having to understand
like all the different segments that
um happen in actual
code parts cool so
any questions before we have one last
thing that we found
so this last thing was probably my
favorite use of interfaces in sphinx
um so again we talked about the http
handler interface which is part of the
net http library
um so we got to the point where like
okay like 6 is really cool
now we really want is dynamic
configuration reload
so we can change the config without
taking on the server
so there's this like top top level game
instruct in sphinx
that uh just like continuously running
came in that
um starts the server and does like all
the
instant like configuration loading and
stuff like that um so the statement has
a handler field on it that is the http
handler that we saw earlier
the logger limiter depending on what the
config has
um and the way that the daemon worked
originally was it would just call
listen and serve with the handler field
of the damon
from its own start method um so we were
able to
add trivial like trivially add
configuration reload by making the
daemon implement the http handler
interface
by adding a survey to the method that
just call the survey should be method of
its handler
and then change it into the start method
to start a server with the game instead
of the damage handler
um and then you just need to recall load
configuring on the game in a second or
third time which you can do from
and this works because the old handler
um is like no longer on the game and so
i'll do new requests for the new handler
but
um any requests currently that were sent
to the old handler are going to finish
before it gets cars collected
so it's like trivial configuration
reload that worked perfectly
um yeah questions
so it looks like this is like
uh yeah so the question was like why is
uh so sphynx is actually a collection of
self packages and there's like a
main function that imports some of
yourself packages to load it so twelve
our services are written in multiple
languages
and so on ago we did not want to
implement all of this in
every language also it's really hard to
test what request latencies could add
if it was part of a bundled kind of
service that did many other things
we are a big fan of having our services
completely
separated so sphinx for example doesn't
do
any advanced proxy it can only proxy
into one back-end
because there are many other services
that do that very well
however we did try using engine proxy
and nginx and using their
rate limiting and they were not
comfortable enough they did not
do advanced bus processing or do
multiple parameters
so that those are the features that we
wanted
um so in memory yes so there's a lot
like
in memory we use
yeah it's not thread safe and
however in redis it we use
a multi-exact block and also
i think we use the procedure to run the
so yeah so you basically can
write a combination of steps
okay
yes so so yeah this is one of the things
that
you know we found out bugs in this
because there were certain things that
the in-memory implementation
made very easily uh visible that
it would have been hard to find in redis
but since we had already had tests on
the expire edges we did find those
issues
in redis those issues are solved by
setting the expired properties properly
and so
if you look at the redis implementation
it uh
there it is there is importance in at
what point you set the expire field
uh so that you get the right behavior
for pockets that don't get hit again
until the very end of when they're going
to expire
um
oh yeah so um so
i do not have the numbers in my head
right now but there
are if you run
make bench on the repo it gives you
comparisons between the redis packet and
the in-memory back-end
which is going to be exactly the number
that you're looking for
and uh it was a significant number the
difference between just using things in
memory
and doing a network round trip but it
was something also that was very
important for us
yeah and it was low enough compared to
the time our services actually take to
respond
like so the back-end server took a lot
more time than the overhead of the redis
back
thank you